une entame de seconde période
déterminante dans ce 16ème de finale de
Fédérale 2 très serré entre les deux
équipes 10 partout à la mi-temps plaisir
est en position favorable pour marquer
un essai
mais les lieux de Saint-Priest
intercepte et mènent ce contrat à Saint
difficile à digérer pour les plaisirs
nous fait mal nous fait mal parce que en
fait c'est sur ces couleurs c'est soit
nous marques soit c'est eux voilà c'est
un coup du sort donc ça fait un peu mal
à la tête surtout à la reprise comme ça
mais bon il y avait encore 38 minutes
derrière donc voilà c'est vrai qu'on a
pas su on n'a pas su rebondir et
pourtant plaisir à dominer cette partie
contre les joueurs du Rhône mais comme
le dit le coach Sébastien rocali n'est
pas gagné encore une fois l'adage
c'est valorisé aujourd'hui pour nous
malheureusement au niveau de
l'implication des gars il y a
strictement rien à dire par contre en
termes de maîtrise effectivement on a on
n'a pas su conclure dans les zones de
marque et on savait très bien que
notamment phase finale ça fait la
différence donc ça c'est vraiment
dommage maintenant maintenant il y a
quand même de très bonnes choses à
retenir donc voilà on sait que on sait
que c'est pas fini
on a vu ce qu'on était capable de faire
face à cette équipe donc bon on va
essayer de tout donner sur le retour
rien n'est perdu pour les plaisirs wah
ils se sont inclinés 10 à 18 sur ce
match aller et sont prêts à tout donner
lors du match retour à l'état d'esprit
de conquérant il va falloir aller là en
plus on a du retard on part avec moi 8 -
8 points donc voilà esprit de conquête
et puis de surtout se faire plaisir
parce que là aujourd'hui on s'est pas
fait plaisir du tout
plaisir sera en mission ce dimanche 14
mai du côté de Saint-Priest dans la
région lyonnaise